I hate but the thing is it's been banded
a lot once of food podcast was full
podcast welcome to the waffle podcast
we're live right now I think on
youtube.com ATC and if you're listening
to right now this is the worst awful
podcast it's not first of all sports
it's not bloom on a podcast that's a
time let the dollar parking at the
punch-drunk long podcast
it's the word self full podcast so if
you're here to look for self Tripoli
he's right outside the office right
there are now on a razor scooter with
any Pepitone filming some video and go
watch them at cutting Pepitone he wrote
as he were a matching shirt for that
scooter so that's a little weird right
to have a green tea like nowadays if you
put a green shirt on and if you're real
famous it might be an old Shana pop put
something on it the green screen that
one so Sarah how could we ever to her
brought you were a green dress and over
man I saw one and it made her look like
a [ __ ] pool table the blaze starring
kids
what's up fool without Johnny rocky who
wear the original Captain save-a-ho
shirt size small maggot compliments on
this shirt I bet you do that fist bumps
off on people yeah man yeah
right now I'm everybody's doing the old
at the old um the face app right now
everybody downloading it a hundred
million downloads of it Sam and
everyone's doing it bro
some of them look good like Bush
Escobar's tried out G hammer their son
and look like Bush Escobar and his dad
and then some of them look like weird
bro like you can't even tell they put a
face out
nobody will join Cobo deal with a good
one oh yeah he look like the wizard from
Lord of the Rings huh
he's like a fat Anthony Bourdain
I did what bro and up a bunch of people
at the show the last show we did was
there now he's Houston I know Chicago
and our two shows are those are people
took a photo with and I made myself into
a baby does this fool doesn't mean yeah
let that out man I haven't tried it at
all you haven't well Eric rob was here
man author and creator of the his first
book super torta a blue-collar guy out
of Riverside California
who written a kids book inspired by
himself who actually he wrote this book
in first grade or second grade and let's
talk about that first of all it was
great yeah damn you drew that that was
great yeah have a the original book
which I couldn't find
but it's somewhere in my house when
you're a kid at the gym create a book a
comic book
yeah I like little things drink but you
never like it like made your own comic
book it's like a flipbook type of thing
yeah you I did my own prayer book can be
published it without your consent
but everything little hands do the
fighting
you know Haru some cuts everything
mother
st. Thomas I used to uh every I feel
like God on my on my books or whenever
they had as a school book or whatever my
notebook I saw it like a boarding class
bro I should do like stick figures bro
poured so you pull you pull the page
together to hurt the running or I mean
oh my god those doing those just do it
as a kid view of not be a cartoon but
then I know that um it's a team of
people doing it bro not like one person
going one by one like what maybe what
didn't do that we had the first one the
first being equal no usually though yeah
he did it like that he started in the
shed yeah but it's a team but they're
not all drawing every cell anymore you
just animate you just draw a few images
and then you animate them in oh man I
hate to be a weirdo no library right cuz
I live in a project so those Benjamin
Franklin library but or you can go over
there get risk you risk getting jumped
by a bridge Street grant gang of Reed
Street Arthur Street gang or tiny boys
or [ __ ] so like those routes bro to
go to the library so I'm I suppose a
library man and I know what the library
chose in seventh grade but I'm it to be
a bookmobile bro and I for show a little
van bro if reading is fun he will show
up and to be a van illegal check up with
her the band brought me a hardy boy
couch he'll come twice here's give me
the other week yeah we got betrayed that
book bro they were not for sale so there
was a book to brother I think I jacked
it but I'm not sure cuz what I did I'm I
ripped the rip the cover off you know
we put the little slip and walked out so
whatever I don't know if I stole it but
I'm gonna quiet checked it out and
brought it back but there was a series
of books about movies and they'll give
you like a little bit of the movie in
the book and a head and I had a sir and
I have fever wrong and then like the
corner pages you flip it and it was
judge of what's at dancing oh I love
those kind of books that have that in
the corner that was rare that was yeah
Mel like a second-grade people little so
I was always drawing bro yes well you
will draw this little kid bro that's how
it started actually I think why super
torta bro but not super taco or super
menudo I was little
basically I think everybody remembers
mean like like when I was in elementary
school that three thought has a little
warm ball that that's actually packing
tortoise for his field trip that's what
that was me in middle school I would do
that three thought that yeah was that
field trip you know I always expect the
worst
well yeah that's how that's a literally
how why taught us and everybody kind of
remembers because of that obsession for
tortoise and the teacher I remember one
kid forgot his lunch they asked me if I
could give him every lunch brought over
this kid like I look there why even call
me family last money a little kids were
like you're looking at me eat my had the
worst lunch everybody look at me man why
even come bro a state when to come to
the future period so you're waiting for
the bus for their life to show up you
know all right could we have our lunches
that will come to you know like you know
in the classroom that whatever future we
took in our school our lunch followed so
there was like a little to lunch
those so much money they were they were
giving away again for the school
district that there was actually lunch
ladies that went to the showed up and
gave it our lunch and then but those
kids brother they have sandwiches and
hammer sorta that was me
we even call me that's what we daddy oh
really
welcome we will look at all the schools
bro and it was like like schools with
budgets like the white schools so
sometimes like everybody from every
school gesture where we'll be at the
alleys or the museum right and then you
start looking around Berlin
Wow were there the rich kids I would
always think and there are matching
shirt with her name on it just because
they get lost like they're never gonna
get they're never gonna lose Judi bro
she wears a red t-shirt just like Keith
and Kevin in Kelvin and Jennifer I'm
right here bro bro we're the only one
okay don't lose your partner we're
holding hands the buddy system nothing
[ __ ] huh I don't think I ever had a
buddy system in my field trips no no
okay so the outskirts of LA my backbone
or one Oh Lucy rivers that good nor bad
nor walk right by the one ways literally
no walk walk walk if she has an RV in
her front yard that wood chip will is
right and for in my life people get mad
at when you mention them you should be
gathered mission you know yeah doctor
said the worst is what nobody mentions
you know more like you come to the park
and nobody's talking about your dad
you're forgotten bro you're in the midst
in the abyss right like go home for
recipe.i notionally bone refresh
- I'm insane I just followed that song I
will watch beauty of a rabbit with
[ __ ] ears and I didn't know that that
was part of the Coco song well where do
I put my head I don't know I don't know
Leo the lap Coco then huh
he sang a bunch of songs yeah if
somebody was saying it was from Coco we
said oh we didn't know because we
weren't who didn't we never saw Winnie
the Pooh blustery day with the record
that I can't you know that no rabbit
puffer hola
[Laughter]
no rabbit man little one no Carlos -
hello had a little business hat on money
the pool I like to sing about the moves
so but you saw Purdue zero book yeah
yeah exactly I said I said on this idea
for like six years seven years honestly
I think it one of those things where I
kind of wasn't too confident in myself I
was just like this is like two Mexicans
nobody's gonna be interested in this
this is like yeah but I think it once I
you know me the media kind of speaks for
itself kind of people all these channels
started popping up and all these people
like and on Instagram it's like you know
what this is this is nice this is like
then it opened the floodgates to what
people kind of wanted it see on TV and
books and stuff so yeah like a good
niche market oh thank you
and and again that like I said it's one
of those where I was like you know I'm
gonna take just do it this year and
that's exactly why I started that's
funny you say you thought it might be
too Mexican because it's I mean I'm not
Mexican at all but being married to one
I know but I know yeah we got condiments
No
the book about oily bro he said he was
working on it and he thought this might
be too Mexican right but it's I think
it's mexican-american and it's very
American but it's it fits it's not
Mexican at all it's a Mexican American
thing and that's a hard thing to teach
Hollywood and to teach you know like the
book industry or whatever you know the
publishing industry but it's hard to
teach people that there's a whole it's
different it's in between it's this
in-between culture yeah all takes place
here in LA yeah and I'm part of those
areas are actually can I kind of infuse
like real locations in downtown LA where
I spent you know some of my time in
college
I'm Gabriel is permission for the legs I
take pictures with anyway as I'm looking
[Laughter]
what's your favorite too fast too little
speedy taco more powerful you wanna no
no my favorite told ya I can't say no
more but now hanging out more about my
favorite store that was the one from and
[ __ ] okay help me out here Pecan
Street a pecan Park Murray your brownie
Murray or smart Camarillo torta shout
out to rob a listening room Oreo store
just a basic Manny's slice a Monterey
Jack cheese
having cheese imagine he'll come on they
want tomatoes onions and a [ __ ]
jalapeno inside wrapped in a wax paper I
always put the yellow
I'm sorry gonna toast it or no no no you
don't toast it whatever toast with
Aleppo continue her baby right now
she had no toaster
they were really made refresh Fresno
just sit it down account
brother Miley Sookie is good it's at
Ulta man yeah the bread already good
enough to know people complain man would
happen would you last night it was nasty
bro were happy bro
there were a sport a where you had to
make me one and she was changing a baby
on the side she put extra shitty enough
she would I pay attention there huh yeah
well now just a porta with he will go to
them the guy the guy opposite up the
street laughs our it down Soto and buy
all his peachy bo Leo's in the morning
bro I can't believe that's how can i you
know there is a pompadour no but other
people come get or thing who call them
they fight about it we call them be
wrote this but I've got a bully on now
because when I go to a bakery of the
city a lot of fear that we lose because
we thought that we thought the body they
really sweet it's not find out it's like
a lair you gotta scrape it off bad
people right breaking that [ __ ] bra
you feel about these idiots who are
[ __ ] who are the people that are I
just go to a park a listener
you anymore bill burr anyway so there
was a we think about these paths will
say blow the conch out that I make
they're making them extra big and then
you think that to make a thought attack
Oh gross no I can't never I don't
support that
that's a quickest way to a diabetic oh
yeah that should be his enemy bro
then make a fight against each other
there should be there should be super
throw the enemy because what happened
we're late for both bread no sit on me
you know there's different types of to
don't forget the samhitas and in East LA
they're very popular all over there what
makes it a semi you like it also right
how about the rule the book all right
Rose be dipped all right the French to
get it back what's the other one is that
red sauce that it's soaked in my muscles
barbar saw with a gorilla - and it's
sweet it's a little sweet though right
it gets a little crunchy because of the
sugar and then you know what are you
gonna grill it for bomb Bosco came
around and I'm late nineties in my
neighborhood because my neighborhood we
had ceviche we had burritos and tacos
and maybe uh somebody made a tort or a
quesadilla
but they're like more immigrants were
coming bro yeah and then I went to Boyle
Heights one time right there it was a
breed Street across the street from
breed Street Elementary School right
before you get to see the Chavez and
there were like three trucks right there
in the neighborhood and one of them was
bam ba saw the other one thing me say me
and the other one was something else
I've never heard of
yeah well that oh there's all kinds like
a it was like different shapes and sizes
watches cause they're different now
Oh watch your lon I G TV Instagram and
somebody put like what was whether what
a cheap whatever they put they put the
masa whatever right but she put bees in
it for black bees and then they laid out
flat then Friday and then at the past or
another
funny that's how they make that's how
well they make it over off of your kill
something why not just deca yeah I just
that shout-out to themselves good dope
what may have fabro everything man not
stopping how money tell me we put in New
York baby like 2500 a day like per meal
25 wanna maintain per meal yeah
depending on your weight and height
depending on your height if you want to
maintain you want to stay under like
2,000 calories a day but you know Big
Mac Big Mac meal is like 1,100 calories
man I'm Taco Bell burrito bean and
cheese burrito 300 calories each one
ketchup in my super over like 5000
easily so don't consume it unless you're
ready to you know you are a fat boy yeah
the name bum bum ya supposed to be like
you're fat there's a video of me chubby
kid boys in the hood you just fat you
eating [ __ ] oh when he was a little kid
boy boy how did it go
you saw how the month telling him you
fat you eat you know he's all you just
like your dad you know be [ __ ] so um how
many are in a book tour right now you've
been wanting a book we can we both find
super Dada you guys can find it on super
torta book.com I mean it's all right not
all online I'm working on some local
book shops here in the area right now to
get it in there so little by little yeah
yeah I'm not expecting everybody to come
and buy yeah at once by all the book it
was bad
are you doing any reads support
libraries of kids or anything yeah I'm
really trying to get to some of the you
know neighborhood pretty much le area
yeah library yeah basically anywhere
like we're are hand-picked yeah but the
one thing it's like a lot of people are
even putting made a video on my website
that explains what a torta is because
you know a lot of people have been
asking me you know Asian background you
know white people have been asking me
about what is Lane I mean they kind of
know what a torta is but not exactly so
you know I made a whole video about it
in fact how Thor does come in like
people could be come in different shapes
and sizes
yeah like us you have torta and only the
spiders thought that shows up and it's a
cake yeah exactly so I think it's the
Spanish people
yes dr. Spinola eggs quiche yeah
did you talk already I didn't I just
came back but did you ask him already
about how you went through the process
of publishing yourself or like how
people can do this if they want you know
have a book idea like how did you do all
this a lot of it obviously what I'm
doing right now a podcast podcast
YouTube videos so you got I mean it's
kind of like get yourself started it was
one of those things where I'm working
with like some publishers right now send
copies it's a gated officially published
but you know the fact that they're
saying that you're already and on your
own you know you're running they don't
need to pick you up on the ground I
think that shows a lot of incentive from
for a lot of people whatever it is that
they're trying to get into you know I
have more ideas for books I want to keep
writing and I guess this is a good good
example for yeah I want to start
whatever it is that they're trying to do
I mean I was you know everybody started
in their own way and that's I'm that's
what I kind of want to inspire other
kids to do like use their imagination
like imagination is not just like you
know oh wow thought about moving around
it's actually you know figuring things
out in life you know and a lot of people
come in like young small neighborhoods
you know sometimes we're like very
limited by that and that to me so what
I'm preaching in this like that
imagination has can guide you through
the corporate world whether it is like
just starting a small business or you
know making your own product
yeah man seem the bigger vision what's
up fool I like the large I left a large
by the way I've set out to here
he's fighting with Mega Man on on the
chatroom never mind keep through Chuck
I'm gonna Jack those beers they have
their own little world going on over
there though the Warsaw full podcast
chat fight over there anyway so um yeah
we have a guy to manage the large and
sometimes um he makes packages for
underprivileged kids he puts
toothbrushes coloring books how much is
your book I landed with free shipping
right now it's like around fifteen
dollars but make sure you guys use
thoughts I launched 2019 we're gonna go
buy it personally like it somebody want
to buy a bunch of all and put them in
kids bags for Christmas because I did it
a lot of people do out here oh yeah yeah
yeah never even thought of that
to be honest with you doc green stuff
urges email me super torta that book at
gmail and we can definitely work
something out
yeah it was the Instagram bro my
Instagram super torta dot book on
Facebook YouTube a little bit little
getting up there shut up - Eric Ramos
people look out for you well my show I
was I was at your show the Spanish or I
Spanish show in comedy store in Long
Beach oh yeah Tuesday yes how was the
show but you liked it
did you understand it was funny yeah
exactly I did understanding and hey
what's I don't know and once I got
comfortable with I was funnier man yeah
there was the one without one people
kept kind of like trying to like you
know fix your Spanish I'm just like
throw firecracker
Alec the large he thought either he's a
good guy in a community he's always like
he though he's helping people out man it
and now he always prescribes a hundred
people every week when he goes out to
the Apple store
what thank you very much man I hope you
guys are gonna work huh yeah yeah I'm
still I'm still the blue-collar guy
blue-collar authors all good bro child
but Cosby had a job you never quit you
still have a job right now I guess yeah
I do background work I find [ __ ] to pick
up on the road you know survive yeah
yeah oh well thank you bro we got jacob
vargas right here thank you oh [ __ ]
well so what is happening all right well
thank you so much for having me guys
thank you
so the element check out super taught
the people not to be mistaken by you
guys sorry I should've brought more yeah
the baby in the way bro
first book awesome I already been
reading to that for another one of them
to me
play some Mozart dog well so Jacob
Vargas beatbox on that stomach what's up
fool what's a full time bro you're
killing me bro what happened but I just
you should get to see Momo Garcia's show
he was wearing a purple coat a hat no
yeah looking like Barney or one
good talk but Wyndham old school shoes
though but nobody wears bro remember the
old school one they have like on my tips
I don't know they're black with a little
black thing a pony world they're nice
hmm no what kind of shoe a moral do
don't worry the one that had the black
tips are wingtips but they kind of look
like spats bad yeah
changing the game dawg changing that
game done a fool that Benny man up bro
[Laughter]
adding extra detail down low bro yeah
you were a kids book saying bro my
sister dog team eggs Latina extra extra
else
what's up full bra ever I don't know if
I emailed you one time out of the
and I asked you if you knew Don Simpson
Don Simpson from I'm still in Brooklyn
yeah if you work with a movie with him
right there yeah because I read the
whole book I don't know you knew much
about him that book is called not really
bro but my concept right I concept right
yeah he and Jerry Bruckheimer had had
their company did a bunch of these crazy
yeah Flashdance ooh the first want to
put crazy-ass music like a soundtrack
that's gonna be the gonna more hit right
with the movie they were also the first
you have no right to ask me how I'd be
late night they had the first like black
white cop movies or buddy yeah yeah yeah
what I did Crimson Tide for them with
you so it was a tide roll tide was
there's a Washington in verbal GMAT yeah
bro and you know James Gandolfini even
had had a Viggo Mortensen I mean it was
it was uh you know great cast man I saw
that anyway bad yeah it was like a
submarine did I had like two lines or
three lines but I was on that thing like
three months so it sometimes we like get
dressed up I was playing a sonar man and
we could you know dressed up and then
all of a sudden you know I wouldn't work
I just be chilling like in my trailer
for like weeks cuz I feel fat checked
but that when the checks were fat you
know back then bro when you know when
you can make a movie hits a hundred
million dollars then you guys I remember
10 years ago or two years ago I was like
you know get rid glass yes and then like
he told me that you got one of your
checks fro Crimson Tide aha how much it
was they were like whoa like they keep
coming 100 days to come bro oh yeah like
I said if you did a hundred million
dollar movie bro you're getting like
thousand dollar checks like all the time
that but that was back in the day
my last residual check was like two
dollars she gots mom yeah so he got some
more quick good that was back when the
DVD thing was big and
you know people were renting movie but
that's before the fire stick came out
yeah yeah no but I got a check for like
what like zero sense bro wow that's more
to mail it I go so why the mailman put
it you know like 7-eleven they got a
little thing of the penny to put in
there Wow three zero zero was talking
about with happy days checks cuz he said
yeah they were found in the beginning
and then he said then they were just
like 50 Cent's here and that because it
becomes cheaper as they sell it multiple
times
yeah yeah I mean I still don't know how
that process works how they determine
you know when your show was on or who
saw it or how much yeah I had no idea
all I know is that when you get these
checks in the mail and yeah I would walk
it into the auto I walk into the bank
with like a stack I like literally like
a stack like this full of checks you
know and they add up to like 10 bucks
but if your child support you get more
and if you if you pay the child support
already hey I pay my child support like
I don't nothin right but you know child
support
works slow you know but so they still
might take a check might take money out
of my check I remember getting a stack
of checks bro for a dollar seven bucks
six month there were eight sorry we took
it out of your check my by said I like
the way they [ __ ] I'm sent you the the
money right away and faster they take it
away yeah yeah brother
but now now we've got like direct
deposit so that's uh when you're okay
boy it's different huh you don't get
that money like before huh where we're
gonna work cable or no we're cable
Netflix is nice bro no no yeah
what was that yeah but so the very good
was FX yeah yeah but it was okay it was
okay but the camera I came in like
season six you know I mean you're gonna
spin off two of them so you don't have
any history with the Mayans at this
point there's no crossover yet I mean
with the show nothing yeah that time
period I think you know they're keeping
the to mythology separate honestly I
don't know you know it'd be great to
come on and be on that show but because
I'm a fan of the show it went bad as if
yeah um Jacobs character was like one of
those club that was overtaken by the
Sons of Anarchy when it did the switch
over there like sometimes that they
would go in to grab a little ass Club
you know like in real life a little ass
Club to have ten but but they have a
rival gang you know the riving against
another gang
so they [ __ ] team up with sons of
anarchy wasn't my idea but I feel like
but if anybody from the sons would cross
over it would be would be Montez cuz you
know right Mexican bro
so yeah so I think you know he'd be a
great person to to cross over but you
know ala bro I'm you know right now I'm
doing other things and so but if if they
call I'm ready bro I still got my vest
my closet so I charge 10 bucks an hour
yes if you were to wear the cut I was
born in Michoacan Michigan Michigan
McMichael ever I was born shotgun but
then my you know we moved to California
when I was like a year year and a half
and with that the dick you change I
broke my parents say no you were one it
said no you were - no you were one and a
half so I don't really know for sure but
it was it was somewhere around there but
somewhere before two years old well we
moved to like some Valley and then we
moved to Pacoima and we that's what like
Jacob bro he not there bro claiming
there I'm a son of an immigrant
my immigrant just told us but he's not
exploding it to the world bro like some
people like not exploiting it exploiting
initiative we know now we know yeah shut
they have a bird back it was it was now
now bro I can't kick but I think my way
out of a paper bags man lost it all as a
key to [ __ ] with Baltar I did bro yeah
we were thrown into it and when we were
kids man we our first language was to a
Spanish spec but but then we started
going to school and our impre it was
just a massive system where they would
tell my parents look if you want your
kids to succeed in this country you got
to speak English and so you know we said
alright cool then we're not speaking
Spanish anymore and we just spoke
English total immersion Raul no yes so
it was just come because you just didn't
have yourself oh no I remember being a
kindergarten bro and and when my first
memories was being a kindergartener just
playing with blocks in the back because
I didn't understand what the hell was
you know was was going on what the
teacher was saying yeah yeah so my
teacher was a American right in
kindergarten and I remember just
pretending I knew what she was saying I
guess I was like not right and i
remember much of a memory I just know
that when it was they had everybody
stand up and go and do the ABCs I
stopped that tea I didn't know the rest
bro
so I go back and sit down okay hell yeah
yeah think so I don't know I think about
it I come just for example this is
basketball player I really took place
it's my know I don't know if I started
play he gave her Mexico played and I
went to school and I mean Ohio I guess
but I try to put him in Hispanic class
he was not my put me in American let
someone learn English fast yeah mm-hmm I
mean it does work if you go to another
country and you want to learn that
language total immersion that's the way
to go and you don't know anything for a
long time but yeah right my parents go
12 you gotta get yourself yeah we apply
if you've worn it and you don't need
that long even speaking that line of
that lights it's it's it's you gonna
fall way behind I remember kids in our
class that would come from Mexico and I
remember will do what Ken had a mustache
bra so he must've been like yeah Robin
he was like third grade class because
they had to put him back because he just
couldn't you know yeah and then they
don't get hooked up or they don't
understand they drop out and then follow
in my high school head with your high
school in my high school all the ESL
kids were also in ROTC ROTC mm-hmm and
it would take bribes roll all right I
will call it was all the federales over
here well yeah man a PC some paint a so
the ESL in our school with a bunch of
Mallett Latino kids from from Central
America of Salvador and Mexico but also
there was like four Russian kids could
there's been no [ __ ] English at all
and they were that was their crew man
like Russian kids and auspices other
yeah and how the outsider and the
Russian man speaks Spanish faster than
English oh yeah immersion I guess make
kind of makes sense you know cuz like my
parents have been in this country for
like 40 something years and and they
still can't speak English I guess
because you know you surround so people
that speak Spanish you just never have
to get out that bubble yeah get out of
that bubble and out of that comfort zone
gelatin people who live in New York bro
like the Dominicans they could survive
the whole whole life that every journey
that's true Romeo Santos right what's
off what I thought you where'd you grow
up at then everyone Pacoima Ricci yeah
Ritchie bro George Lopez George Lopez go
splashing chichi Cheech Marin
Cheech was like more like Granada Hills
but it's all the same but Danny Trejo
what were you like in the 90s like 91
90s bro I was no Bryan graduated high
school Wow oh they rehab
okay but I was in rehab bros I'm family
in the raccoon Valley but you're not
there by living like a half of them okay
all right yeah that's not yeah are
frequently used to be a living in
recovery home shout out to pasture
Jessie Higuera and I def well we right
there bro but then we move to our Sun
Valley no that's not Valley we moved at
Sun Valley we want to [ __ ] um
Saugus Saugus okay we're more people and
we just see a lot of food for Pacoima
coming to Brooklyn GTECH got those bones
yeah a lot of heroin in the neighborhood
but how did you escape all that shaker
that's that's the other no man this
Pacoima gang cholos with dissolvable
cover Crips GoPro and like yeah man like
they were they were crazy believe would
have froze bro they were in my rehab and
they're like what am I here for Pacoima
[ __ ] yeah cuz and then are you from
Pacoima and it was I don't really know
this family and and I put corner but we
should get a lot of them come in though
this do that came in bro he had a big
coin my pockets right here and then his
last name in the front seven that we got
along because I was my mom's maiden name
okay no I don't know those dudes but no
bro I mean I said I grew up I grew up
with around a bunch of Bloods actually
around Vaughan Street and so I remember
bro IRA being a kid dude what our
friends you sell crack you know back in
the day so we'd go over and just kind of
hang out with them and while they're
like oh hang on bro we'd be like you
know hang another go ahead I'll be back
in two minutes they go Carl pull up bro
they sell some crack oh oh let's go
brother
no houses just run up to the car brand
we get getting shot at bro you know but
it didn't seem out of the ordinary just
seemed like that or more normal braches
life I probably would that's how I
thought man I live in the projects like
to the outside world I would eat food
find crack but it would have every day
job like yeah I will get up in the
morning brush my teeth pick up my five
rocks you go bruh
but I was like I got 9 to 5 hours but
thereafter while there was more people
something cracked that wouldn't have to
stay late at night you should grow
boredom or do something
so plan the man Briana something small
piece well big piece of really Jacob by
dieter morning
no prob I never got involved with it
with that bro like I luckily I got to
break that know everywhere yeah I was
everywhere bros everybody
yeah I gotta break dancing I think
bright star makes with the leg yeah wore
bandanas oh right I go that far bro Bank
good yeah how's girls good bro yeah
that's why I got into inter interacting
Wow yeah crew name Street motion Street
motion man yeah bro we're like local
celebrities because we did a murder back
in a neighborhood like Telemundo
Univision did a telethon every every
Christmas called Navidad another battery
oh wow oh yeah give away toys exactly
but that's what it was and so so we went
and we we did a you know breakdancing
bit and everybody saw that bribery was
watching it so so we became like local
celebrities man and yeah I'll say buddy
that do from Mario yeah and and yeah
where we go like people say break dance
dance you do this in the end so this you
know I got discovered break dancing by
by manager and she became my you know
who a manager like when you started want
to act yeah yeah yeah my first gig ever
was as a break dancer on an episode of
Diff'rent Strokes by the GU time yeah
like Oh in you know I guess uh Todd
bridges was already off the show yeah
you know dana plato was off the show it
was like he had a ham you hit a little
brother Sam you had a little country
singer yeah yeah it's funny he was
singing every episode he always had some
kind of thing so like in our episode he
sang a song about like off-the-shoulder
blouses you know because like they
outlawed breakdancing and of the
children blouses in the school and so we
were like weird like picketing yet is
where ever I love off-the-shoulder
blouses
these were breakdancing in my junior
high school and then like a big color
coming in the principal that scoop Oliva
break it all right and then so we had
store they stopped that and then like we
have to instead like they gave us a
chance to put up a show and do this okay
and it was different you're gonna it's
different watching it from the sitting
down maybe nobody likes you know being
like watching no man I'm right I did a
show in in junior high a play and you
know during like remember nutrition when
they had nutrition yeah and so every
good like every get like free fruit and
milk and whatever so we're in our same
bar as grilled cheese yeah but all the
apples flying at me Verizon oranges
first time car the chocolate milk bras I
did they weren't having it start I was
but it was a bunch of breakdancing
oh yeah no Chinese shoes you know you
wore the little shoes but with zero
support but it was flat as hell ninja
stars I don't yeah we used to watch that
kung fu theater where that guy yes of
channel 5 dr. Lambros okay okay China
fight will have cone full week bro show
the world work is a kid you watch movies
and the next day you chose do those
moves nothing but rip pass on to bro
yeah would your favorite
kung fu movie well answer dragon of
course but there was a lot of them that
we saw on TV
right poor my favorite one bro worth
[ __ ] your master the guillotine bro come
on
we should get away you got a way out bro
in a chain and the lampshade on front of
our brother head and it just yank here
Brooke I think that ya know that was
like that movie the master of the flying
guillotine the first fight of that movie
and like the pritam of the basis of
every other fight movie you're gonna see
in the future Mortal Kombat because
there was an Indian fool had arms that
grew now right right yeah yeah brother I
had like they're that weird like magical
like fighting path I don't know full of
the monkey boy that the dark is
character the movie yeah yeah yeah and
then i rewatch that man and then it was
a look he got beat by the Asian girl
with a tiger
okay Ryan and there was a grasshopper
with the grant of the locust one yeah
yeah
Levin though the badass do that he
should have we should maybe he was like
a TIE fighter a Thai boxer huh okay yeah
man I'm looking for that one on a boxer
that's film a there's a part of the
movie where the food eating a bunch of
food but he's hiding his arm saying he's
a water boxer then the [ __ ] old man
kills him right there for the restaurant
just naturally like man what a boy
yeah bro and after that you go in the
backyard and you start trying to
practice all the moves and yeah yeah I
got like one of my teeth chip cuz my
friend did a back kick and kick me in
the face I don't believe it been a bug
bed my brother is your top man I want to
join Kofu classes leg exercises my
brother a job you know top bug and I've
been a bottom bunk and I'll be lifting
him with my legs will get all mad but
how many and how many brother yet six
brothers so you guys I'll share one room
yeah more bedrooms that don't wonder the
project five of us and one sister but we
all share one room
yeah you're sick 5-1 oh yeah it says
that there were five boys and one and my
my sister had her own room no I actually
know my sister slept with my parents and
then we had all five of us boys shared
one one bedroom and then we had one room
full of like machina psycho said you
know like sewing machines we we used to
make women's clothing back in a day
sweatshop yeah man yeah yeah we had them
up we do it - no but she had a sewing
machine the one the the one the old
school that was your that was the office
those the business five boys in a room
which made women's clothing okay we go
selling it that's what you go to a trash
live by the by the warehouse didn't know
I live right downtown LA so we will go
up my mom you were they have that toy
factory factory right which is our lives
now but my mom you were where they had
to cease to work at this Freedman bad
company and she just separate bags for
these people okay well it's different
about cost alienation all day long so
she knew where they threw away our
synthetic cotton that's nothing stuffy
stuffy poor build-a-bear all that [ __ ]
right here she also she she knew was
through it threw away pillowcases that
were like they were never there fabric
but they were like the dye was bad threw
it away so I'm I will grab all that [ __ ]
take it home and then to grab the cotton
and stuff it with [ __ ] cotton
let your soul pillows and my brother
never the salesmen right door-to-door
style of pillow really okay out of that
go good man yeah
but then once a month
hey like everybody knew was today and
stuff when you go door-to-door your
friend with a pillow right there are
worried or something we'll put the
pillow at home bro these pillows off the
shift to sleep or pillows like sleep bro
you like decadence are you the killing
is your on your friend that's missing
man how about a little time we want
pillows yeah but now like those natural
pillars of the big deal or now yeah I'm
like the full of buckwheat or whatever
you know oh the first movie you were in
first movie I was in was I did a movie
called the last resort I saw that with
Charles Grodin and it was it was it was
it was one of those like really B movies
I thought a little and resort with John
Candy no this is Charles Grodin and we
shot like on Catalina Island supposed to
be some kind of like paradise gone wrong
and and it gets overtaken by like by
this militia and then like Jon Lovitz
was in it I mean had a few of those
resort movies where things go wrong the
one you're talking about club parents
after rod yeah the only like two kids in
the whole movie there are two of us but
it was like row it's like people all
live like on this camp because it was uh
it was shot at a summer camp for for
kids on Catalina Island and so like
there's no place to house that the cast
and crew so everybody stayed in like in
these little cabins and it was just like
everybody's like having sex with each
other and having crazy parties and you
know like yeah you walk right see like
that was your life for many years only
my son what's your name debauchery much
dodge the but come touch easy when I was
in El Sereno there's a braking crew
called meridian
poppers meridian harper and there's
another black dude who was bad
everything will be see rich okay and now
there were another dude and then it was
i'm i don't know where on south gate a
handyman south gate although the guy he
was in roaches crotchety and he do like
the the windmills on yeah he was in the
breaking movies he was in ages yeah yeah
it wasn't him big moment that guy at the
party can't remember his name
not big Allu but the other one just hit
me up man he's uh he's coming out with
like a documentary on his life and and
and he's got to he's got like a Boogaloo
shrimp breaking doll and you know we're
gonna talk about maybe how we can
collaborate and you know maybe do
something together yeah HYAA do you
think he's like a huge inspiration you
remember me familia I wasn't a minute
yeah you were J Lo's husband yeah yeah
and beginning of the movie yeah bro yeah
it was uh it was we were all like young
good a troll bro yeah great mo for you
yeah bro well I uh
I saw my dad broke a rigidly auditioned
for the role of the young Edward James
Olmos put an appeal
yeah which put it but I guess you know
Greg's like look there's movie there's a
great role of other father for the
beginning thank you everybody saying you
look 21
oh wow well just just be broadcast live
is live right now I know that a fun what
are they people to watch right people
ask you questions everything road dogs
with it oh there for quoting a lot of
has pills line okay when is the next
debauchery party I'm married with kids
now brother I'd rather spend two hours
at Home Depot than two hours at a club
and then the foods that were Suavecito
for my vida loca
oh man you only do the loca I will meet
up oh yeah yeah the Suavecito truck
you're American me yeah I played Eddie's
uh he's a little brother and then well
Joker was from next Friday yeah man yeah
no but what well now I'm gonna post the
original script and and because like
there was none of that was written man
and he when he wasn't written funny he
was written like just like basic scary
you know
you know neighbor dude but uh but I
thought yeah I love the first Friday
I remember how funny it was we're not
like dude this is this guy should just
like let loose and just be crazy man and
just you know and just have like zero
like filter and and and you know and so
like luckily bro where I went into the
audition and I just went crazy right
when in the room started Adelaide and
[ __ ] and then the director Steve Karl
was like dude you like when the only
dudes that came in and made him funny
yeah and so when we were on set he's
like dude just just go with it man just
any ideas you you have go with the Bruce
I was like hey man um how about I wear a
thong and I had some boxing and you know
and it was just crazy and he was just
like yeah go for it let's do it let's do
it like the worst that I have it we will
cut it you know whatever no but uh but
but that was I think that was great but
to to allow somebody just the freedom
brought it to be free and and be
creative and I think that's when you get
like magic
hell yeah Bruce know that boy thank you
yeah they can be a part through without
having you in it but we ridiculous yeah
no problem
I talked to Ice Cube Russell and he
definitely said you know Joker's coming
back for the [ __ ] tattoo bro what it
was even on that three or three game
uh-huh all right anyway so that man has
a good row and um somebody says I remind
him from Ernest goes to camp yeah that
was one of my the other one
played bushed
- cool know that we know the kid late to
see another movie look at this another
another actor I don't know still acting
anymore but I'm he was there numb do
your clock hi three o'clock in Moscow
yeah here okay yeah and then I saw you
and I thought I thought that was you
growing they don't see you he said I was
Casey can I study with you Jane's could
mess because I know the one who gives
chichi he's doing to get Paul Rodriguez
the lottery tickets and I'm born in
Italy and he plays every is almost young
row and American me oh really
oh no no no that that's uh that's
Panchito Gomez but you talk over when I
saw America Casey sure my school and
when I saw you together American he's
also in maybe that loca - yeah yeah yeah
man he's a bully a lot of movies like he
was enough - hi hi who was the bully
know that look like how does the move
around that the guy sing in red velvet
or or variable called bullies politics
yeah that's I don't know bro I saw him
years ago in New York and and we we hung
out we partied in New York for a bit but
that's the last time I saw him I don't
know what was in it
okay it's the interaction here are you
there were three 1403 15 it's a
different show I rewind
315 the moment of truth
yeah now that was a yes okay when he
comes to a new neighborhood and it's
Latino and he's a white kid right coming
into the neighborhood nobody but he does
the main bullet I mean buddy the white
dude all right work with with Casey
shemites go though I did I did a Sam
Spade movie the week called called Boys
Town about about the boys town and in
Omaha Nebraska oh yeah yeah I was a does
one of my my my first projects as well
is um is mr. Iglesias oh you're in mr.
Iglesias now on Netflix and is that your
first comedy or is that your first like
series like sitcom a lot of pilots I
know I did a sitcom in 2001 2002 called
greetings from Tucson okay son I played
and I played the the uncle oh okay yeah
so that was fun that we shot you know 22
episode we did a full season and then
you know we didn't get picked up for the
second season but but whether they're at
it was it was on WB and it which is now
the CW okay back in the day but yeah
proper we were right after like the Reba
McEntire show man so and you know which
was that my daughter loved that did the
total different audience for us man so I
did they say no you're not holding on to
her yeah right so but yeah but that was
my first sitcom actually this is only my
second time doing I love it but sitcoms
great was it hard to shoot mr. Glaser
the Jets to work is a different from
shooting for like a network or Netflix
because we like because I know like I
don't know what I did a show what I'm
not gonna compares to other show but
it's just a bum rush all the shows on
that one yeah or just take your time I
mean we had a shoot where the schedule
so it was weird
we had to do you know one a week but
then we got like breaks so in between so
it wasn't it wasn't you know too crazy
it wasn't like
one show a week yeah yeah so we did yeah
it was like yeah show a weekly show a
week and we'd get like a two week break
and then we do another you know another
three if I forgot what the schedule was
but but it we're gonna work produce it's
great bro yeah man it is but also bro
what I loved about the sitcom was you
get that that immediate reaction from
the audience man and then that's you
know and that's one thing I got to give
it up to gay man he he said look I want
to do I don't wanna do a single cam I
wonder I want he's he's so good in front
of that audience man he's really he
knows how to really live audio yeah yeah
but I know like I hear a lot of people
commenting like about a laugh track like
what did this let but we don't have a
laugh track this is like a real audience
sitting in the studio
laughing to to the jokes and and gay
will be engaging with them in between so
they were just energized but they were
you know so they were just laughing and
having a great time
so that's so that's what you you hear
when you hear the laughter on the show
that's cool yeah it's like actual people
yeah yeah bro it's a and and people just
at sunnybrook people who were already
laughing before the punchline you know I
mean it so that's that's how how much
people were enjoying the show he had
heard a lot of his fans there too and as
the audience yeah yeah yeah he's got
such a like a loyal following and you
know his fans man his fans are great
yeah yeah is this have you don't get
cast much for comedy do you go do you go
out a lot for comedy roles or do people
think of you for that or I just think it
kind of goes and says you're good I
think you'll remember you you know by
your last project if you do cuz you know
I hear like Shannon's Friday I did in
degrees from Tucson but then after you
know I did traffic yeah and it was
dramatic and it won all these awards and
we've won like a Screen Actors Guild
Award so people started like right as
dramatic okay even when when when I was
up for the role in in mystical SES and
we saw how to kind of prove to them that
I could be funny you know so I had to do
like I had to do a chemistry test with
with with Gabriel you know so the
president
alpha Roble they call them happy now
Britt was just mean gay brother just
meet me gave him the room with with
everybody else broke and like a
semi-regular and then you ease your way
in that way but you don't opportunity
bro like I always heard that you were
doing a show and then you you had a
pilot and you're more yet I mean dustin
ybarra which one last year too and that
also what happened with the pilot well
this didn't know it didn't go to shoot
it it went to script but no shooting on
that one and then this last one same
thing that we pitch yeah but whatever we
still with we're still working with Vin
Diesel production company yeah we're
with one okay all right they still you
have blood radiator
store a few times because they like him
like that guy like if you get the whole
audition process like when you get the
part
you know that you get the booking and
then we're gonna do a screen test like
if you're gonna be a regular series
regular right so then how does the
screen test go do they give you sides to
do with them do they just want to talk
or yeah and they film you during this
yeah so it's a yeah they think they give
you the sides they give you the scene to
to play and then but but you know then
we started improving yeah just want to
see how if he throws something at you
how how how quick you can respond or are
you gonna get stuck because here because
gay blood like The Improv a lot you know
that they're gonna change it up
especially one on tape days online show
that yeah
but that's the best because could the
audience you know is really you know
they hear it once they they hear the Jo
they get it by the time you do it three
four times yeah I guess old so he always
like to go hey bro let's let's change it
up man let's uh you know let's change
this line that line run and they kept
the audience you know constantly
guessing it won't be told them this
great was fun man yeah I had a blast bro
okay but he's so good at it but you know
like it gets comedians but you guys you
guys know how to out how to come up with
stuff on the fly you know to have to
make it fun about with you go bro did
you but you got like that actor in a
quality where it just comes out like
watching you on the show you're very
like you take away a lot of these on one
episode season two bro here we have your
characters like a horndog or something
been a player but he doesn't know how to
be a player situation you don't you
doesn't understand that that in this
environment you know you can't do
certain they've got no game anymore man
the game has changed the game is and he
just hey don't have any change yeah mr.
chordate oh man like my secret teacher
uh his cologne he wore were the one that
kids gave him the magic word a date and
will you wait who gave you this Oh
Philippe Esparza
to give you this
he wishes no
bracer Wow old-school it will just
double blue look a little green with Old
Spice
Jabra with knit with a bottle Louise
formerly known as to what guy it was 10
episodes which are ten episodes yeah it
depends but I don't know man I don't
know what they're doing how they they
calculate things man they got their own
way of how they make money that other so
shrill because of the world they got
think I'm winning the firm bro they got
their goods yeah
the printed money right now yeah yeah
brand with it it was crazy is that they
don't really a man oh no I guess I don't
really rely on ratings or or anything
like no yeah I mean I don't want to tell
people though yeah it wouldn't tell
Kevin Spacey with the race hazard top
secret thing we're like like we don't
even know how we're doing you know I
mean I don't know I kind of gauge it on
like social media yeah we're great
responsible should media people are
loving it they they watch salt and they
want more I want more right away and you
feel a pressure to come up with
something now and watch alone in a row
one a week which can binge all that [ __ ]
I love that right I love that that I
have a choice of okay I can watch it a
week I can watch the whole thing and you
do you bend anything
I do yeah what's your favorite thing
that you've been straight engine now
well the last thing you know besides mr.
Iglesias blessing i binge the when they
see us which was so we binge that I
don't know I got kids man so like so
it's hard to to watch me like that good
I don't want to watch black mirror oh
yeah first four seasons oh my god yeah
like I tried I tried watching a few
things Ben the kids walk in and you know
and I got a pause it happen and you know
and then and it's hard to ever come back
[Music]
think what the last thing we did was I
haven't haven't seen the last season yet
no yeah we're it I'm at five with my son
and he was out of town we finished a few
oh and he said we're still at two with
him well I got what happened season two
I got rushed the kids are like 20 now
right and so so now I'm like I don't
want to watch season three because I
don't remember what happened in season
two so I feel like I got to go back to
season two to watch yeah what was it
like man you're shooting maybe they look
and they go part with it but I never was
dangerous bro
right yeah go back there that was man
brah I remember cruising with with some
of the homeboy just do research you know
cuz Allison okay what you hang out with
these guys and and we were cruising
brought all the sudden man we got hit up
by some dudes in the car next was burn
the dude pull a gun out like that bro
and also shouldn't we head in my
research I'm gonna try acting
I'm gonna act play some of the actresses
in that movie were not actresses I'm no
brother I just go Echo Park huh yeah
yeah bro it's but it's greats like now
you know and the other all you know
they're all grown up they have families
you know that summer entrepreneurs man
they're there you know they have their
own their own businesses or you know
they're doing their own thing so they
moved away from from that life the two
actresses there were no the main role
with you were the actions already yeah
yeah so steady Lopez and and and
Angela's whir whir mouse key and Sakurai
follow them on Instagram yeah yeah so
and so so angels now you know like that
motivational speaker yeah she she has a
big following and she's all about like
you know empowering women which yeah and
you know and and but it's amazing to
demand for this movie like screenings
for this movie like all over the country
cuz you know I get invited to come out
and and you know be a part of it and
meet and meet the you know the public
when we have these events for all so
it's it's great that these films still
remember but I know bro oh yeah I know
about what I just saw maybe the loco bro
who should be called um
polka Highness [ __ ] shot by a hipster
or the black coke right it's funny you
know who the hipster was that I'm I'm
selling coke to uh with she was an actor
uh Jason Lee Jason yes Jason Lobo Jason
Lee was yeah yeah so he went he went
from from buying coke from you look at
to like talking to chipmunks yes before
mall rats yeah yeah the hash back would
you guys shoot me up my familia my
family we shot it in LA I'm like
somewhere in like I don't remember
bright it was he they could we shot when
we shot like somewhere in in in in Santa
Clarita I think cuz we you know it was
supposed to look like like old man go
and then we got shot a Mako we went
Jennifer and I went to to Michoacan we
went to the more Elia and we shot in
this little town called Oak we'll meet
you that's at the beginning of the movie
when we you know when she like did gets
caught in the river and
yeah and loses the baby in the river and
all that so we shot that a miracle yeah
bad bad diarrhea bro the whole time
really bad you really lender the more
alien ago oh yeah I just landed ago
tried this is the best male in the world
so tried the male that was the worst
that are the worst decision ever bro in
the world wasn't a documentary on
Pastora
and they mention is taco prison in
Mexico City bro I know you went to Yale
where Oh
mm-hmm what are they good they really
that good yeah see the realm of 46
really what are they moly I'll bust old
bastard okay
supposedly where it come from ism I
didn't know that I'm you know like I
tell like okay see you go here to buy
I'm talkin all passed all right whatever
right and King Taco but I didn't know
that everybody just a basic way to make
a pastor but then people had their own
low twist right in my eyes sugar or
whatever yeah see I would say I sort of
was more right when you have it but when
you have it on that big yeah on that big
stick in you carve it but a lot of
people don't know make it like that I
guess there's different ways of make it
ain't getting grilled
yeah like that and chop it up yeah
because my mom that makes it in like in
like one of those like crock pots yeah
which is basically just I'll go borrow
right right another one is that little
Constance world Oh your favorite taco
place growing up right I mean in in in
the hood we used to have just these
little talks but nothing really major
like but my mom always made good talk
was man so so she makes that great like
tacos in lingua oh so those weren't when
my favor that my mom my mom makes my mom
used to make those but never like that
Jim because they do it like we took for
her to buy it I see that long after yeah
right yeah I might change it up in the
beginning she said just put the whole
damn thing in bro so you get I've had
yeah you get on the texture you like oh
do but now brush you can feel that she's
clean she modernized it a little bit and
then you can do it a little too much
where you like you steam it too much
it's too like getting soggy and too
soggy dog has to be made right I got the
perfect texture
you know you cannot have a lane what
burrito though it'll be a taco boy I
should probably drop a burrito
well I was under the leanest I want you
go buy a soda I know the guy they're
ordering a lingua burrito
you know chili must sour cream love
grows too well oh yeah oh you mean like
you know when you add rice and be plain
right he's gotta be played but but in
your salsa like a burrito
yeah no no rice be the tomato there's a
surprise in it yeah you were so poor
this next week July 26 I'm coming to
somebody that desert time and Casino
Tucson Arizona
Pasadena July 28 I'm doing our Spanish
shot it's a joke but that tolerance
pignoli see what fire or you know
English there Mucha Pena San Diego July
29 our Spanish show at the comedy palace
that's right the original Greek palace
I'll be there doing a Spanish show also
so more July 30th someone do the Spanish
tourists orders yeah you're famous flour
tortillas that she's good today you
could ask for border I give to you
doesn't have a lot of kiss on yet see ya
August 3rd twice as funny comedy club
coach art why some of your people
kaeleen Texas attend a pastor one flyer
man kaeleen everybody afford horde
our welcome and it's like 30 minutes
away from where they had to shooting
that woke up wake up wake up wake ok
you're awake ok Naples Florida August 9
through 11 man listen I passed out
flyers everywhere where nobody wants to
go see me
August battery 11 after her comedy club
captain Brian man
this guy is the only guy who know that
was people call him captain brother the
maestro and Seinfeld he wants to be
called about one boat two people fishing
about a restaurant with that money also
I'll guess I'm coming to San Jose
McAllen Texas Lubbock Philadelphia I'm
coming to helium's all dates and tickets
at philippi world.com / tour well jill
has a hot show coming yeah if you guys
for those you guys listen live tomorrow
Thursday at the Lincoln House comedy
club in Covina the pollen Tony on them
August 13th v bellows jokes in Spanish
in Riverside let me pay again yeah man
yeah how's Charlie rookie will be
jogging through in Echo Park push-ups
mister yes how's the Spanish going hey
how's the Spanish she shows that had
like do you think like the jokes
translate yeah we do manage that they do
here so far because most of the people
here who are American Mexican what we're
noticing though Canaries yeah they're
bringing their parents they're fans of
his who also speak Spanish but they're
bringing their parents and being like
this is my favorite comedian okay so
they're able to bridge that connects
we were said we were in Long Beach and
it was like I'm you could tell it this
guy never because I was mom and dad they
go they go out it just BBQ BBQ yeah
family's house so this full night he
could tell you I'm super happy with him
with his wife his sister was there his
mom his old ass dad and then when they
were talking they were took it you're
taking photos of the talking he wants to
go 7-eleven they were there were like
200 people there it was funny you're
bridging yeah generational gaps yeah and
it's all that's but people that wouldn't
go watch a Mexican comedian from Mexico
you know me yeah right
there's a difference so it's like it was
like a new thing for them here right
yeah and I think it's great bro they
loved it bro
the opponents are insects to the okay
when you're not more so to knock on miss
hey my first language is with Spanish
royalty okay I understand a lot more now
like like I speak it broke but it's very
Porto you know so like so so people look
at me like rose I'll say [ __ ] wrong like
like do with me and Gabriel Dubrow you
know we'll just laugh oh yeah yours was
more Potro when you see me doing this
cuz he's doing a Spanish and an English
special for no kicks in the fall but the
Spanish one he when he got started in
Spanish was more rough it was yeah wrong
words
yeah brother like whenever I do like red
carpets and then you know they go you
know you do any red carpet all this and
okay hey I'm like sweaty but but then
all of a sudden man like you can tell
the date start looking at you and and
then they kind of yeah they give you
that my god bro and the like and then it
kind of night now you know you just blew
it in Glasgow and pop in huh when they
killed you a traffic Ross I know what it
felt like that I had that effect about
like watching that homie dying Gaul for
the woman begging for another chance
a my cookie dig me up for old times sake
alright yeah bro code that's what's
right involved because you felt like you
know cuz I see he was your friend you
know in the movie but the way you looked
at him for you get along like only an
actor could do it you know like I messed
up I messed up it we could go back right
I think he gave it a look but you can't
go back right yeah yeah bruh and my boy
Emilio Rivera took me out yeah man why
would the Lebanese for a total
amazing man dude as an act bruh he's an
actor's actor man like I yeah right I
just love watching his process bro yeah
man he gets its way he's into a bro but
also like like I love the bottom is that
you never knew what you were gonna get
like he just he didn't give you the same
thing twice you know like everything was
different and from where I learned of
lesson with him was because you know as
we were starting out bro you want lion
he want as many lines as you can get
obviously but there's no ton of stuff
all is written like him him him and he's
like dude I want to say that I shouldn't
say that he's like you know he can give
it a Jacob give that get away yeah you
like but but I learned he's like look
he's like film is a visual medium so you
don't you I say when you can show it you
know so something you can just you know
say it with a look you know with with
with the least amount of lines possible
and that's and that's what was gonna be
more effective instead of someone just
like you know talking talking talking
talking so so now bro like I even Nellie
I try to to look at a role and see like
how can i how can I convey you know this
without having to say so much yeah you
know that let me pass see when you guys
teach each albedo with Salma Hayek and a
thing is to teach the chief somebody
hath passed the surgery to like Jesus is
not poor but but the way your character
was like you your character was like too
excited to know who that was right and
right away I knew right away this was
gonna die right I know but he's too
excited Brahman right he's not coming
collect that's a major cartel this we
just said out loud who he is you wanna
wear know who he is yeah bro he's an
opportunist bruh he you know he's trying
to make it throw that for another buzzer
yeah yeah bruh and that there were
scenes that we didn't shoot in the movie
but that I really liked
for my character but one was like that
that they go to the US side and they go
to like a Costco and they're looking at
all like you know cuz the wife's
complain like our fridge is broken its
net and the red act like a Costco to see
like bro like rows and rows of like food
and you know and like appliances and
knowing like dude like I can't afford
you know any of this man even though
like I'm
you know so like so I think that really
show like you know that he's how easily
corruptible so yeah right yeah yeah yeah
I mean you gotta just you're trying to
make a living right and you don't you
know these cops don't make [ __ ] don't
make sure though that bro so that's why
there's no more it hasn't you know
that's like that's like you know part of
their income because you know they they
gotta make it work did those bribes are
expected on the street house can you
roll your part was that even dough after
you're dead you stress you out for a
favor it's all my wife with that she
knew you was lying it it's deep in my
car I have mcdeere also hell yeah man
you are out great interview bro you're
good thank you back is it over how you
guys just put the last guy left heel
whoa that will be 15 and 1/8 oh no bro
the oldest is 15 I'm sure she'll be 15
in in September 11
yeah you don't ya dirty right cool yeah
usually we're about people watch mr.
Iglesias show on Netflix on Netflix now
so what yeah you can watch all 10
episodes now and you know let me know
what you think hit me up on also have a
hose in oh yeah oh yeah yeah Garcia Oh
Sherri Shepherd that bird we got we got
okay who knows I got the guy Oscar
forget about the Creedence Richard Gant
what'd you get Maggie Gikas on that she
carries Big Lebowski music Big Lebowski
table the waiter I know he was I think
he's like Don King was he Don King in
the Rocky movies I think so yeah yeah
he's great shooter McGavin happy gilmore
it is it's been the most fun working on
this on the show Matt it's got a great
calendar and the young cast is is great
as well man they're really funny
no Shepards Kumail Sherri Shepherd when
I auditioned for Sherri Shepherd when I
auditioned for the Comedy Store very
political back then like it's makes you
have to watch you okay but this is like
if you're a comment that nobody likes
they say you were auditioning and I
never liked your ass okay I will find a
way to sit next to mitzi to block her
for watching you I'll start talking to
you but everybody does it they don't
mean to do it that's the only way they
could talk to her so that are Yap you
know I never get to see you I never get
to see you now okay now that she's here
to see comedian she wanna talk to
comedians complains you know right make
it a good little chance yeah so Sherri
Shepherd sat next to her and the late
Maria Martinez sat next to her okay lock
these [ __ ] oh really yeah
woman's watching but Lizzy blocking yeah
you know bro Sherry's
I love her bro she's such a giving
person man yeah man she cares about you
know she cares about the comedian's bro
she really does what's that we were
talking and goes we're talking about
money and I don't know where she offered
some money I heard you need help Felipe
sound good
I pyatters been on drugs she blew up
before you guys still came back to the
club yes you do yeah yoky yeah yeah no
she's she's she's fine man she's she's
she's got she's gonna she takes over I
should plans all of it when we say hey
would you good together okay I'm on it
she was in a group tag she's like that's
if going on let's go everybody yeah she
handled bladder
she had the planner bro shelter Johnny
broke her eye her falling asleep people
find you in social media broke you know
I'm on Instagram Brody just Jacob Vargas
man verified so make sure he's got the
blue checkmark I'm on Twitter I'm the
Jacob Vargas and you hit me on on
Facebook bro but I'm you know I'm really
on Facebook I kind of people even face
yeah yeah yeah yeah my brother's exto
lady what's her name whatever baby mama
do her mom has a facebook right and she
she picked cello she's played her Tonio
and put a photo Warner to her period
bruh she posted a video who her bloody
pants bro you had a dick though she were
in a car and I get broke 200 car away
somewhere and went wearing white pants
and she started to pivot right there
it's not and she started putting it on
my facebook like the large Center to me
right huh and then like but then I
started reading you know I read
everything bro and then somebody wrote
you did this last week
cochina now this happens you that's now
around man twice a month the funniest
comments I ever man internet always
those social media are now a worldstar
will say [ __ ] like this booty bro fake
implants she's disabled in her comments
but they're going blue
yeah really but a wolf story with
hilarious man what would their main
comments on how fake I said somebody
said girl look like a wisdom tooth this
big but on the side but it would looked
weird as [ __ ] brutal then she gave me a
heart on what so Jacob bargains in the
house people whatever coming out soon
coming out you can check out I got a
movie called the public that's that's
out on DVD right now it's like with with
Emilio Estevez is it's you know it's a
great film with with a great cast you
know a great social message but
homelessness should be out I mean it's
out now it just came out on DVD last
week so you can check that out other
than that I'm just gonna you know
hanging hanging out being a dad just you
know spending time with my kids was so
full podcasting for listening everybody
here yeah be alright